[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing the
creation of the marauders map the
marauders map was one of the most
important tools that harry potter used
to fight against voldemort's forces
it helped him discover peter pettigrew's
true identity barty crouch jr's lies and
kept him one step ahead of professor
snape but have you ever wondered how the
map was created and how it was directly
related to potter's father james today
we're going to answer those questions
and more as we look at the history of
the marauders map history the marauders
map became one of the most important
tools that harry potter would use in the
lead up to the second wizarding war
and that's more than a little surprising
when you consider who created it because
the map's creators were four young
gryffindor boys known as the marauders
who were enrolled at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry in the 1970s
although the four children remus lupin
peter pettigrew sirius black and james
potter
go on to play pivotal roles in the first
and second wizarding wars
you would never have guessed that based
on their behavior at school
despite their academic success they
never seemed the type for inventions
the creators
remus lupin was the son of lyle lupin an
influential employee of the ministry of
magic
as a young boy remus father publicly
called for the execution of a werewolf
named fenrir greyback the idea didn't
stick though and fenrir survived but not
without claiming his revenge
in the middle of the night he infected
lyle's boy remus with lycanthropy
at hogwarts the affliction haunted remus
every month he was forced to hide in an
abandoned house in hogsmeade
in order to prevent remus from ever
attacking his classmates while in wolf
form
if you looked at the boy's sad state of
affairs at the time you'd think remus
was more likely to end up as an outcast
than as an influential professor at
hogwarts another member of the marauders
was the heir of the dwindling black
family sirius iii by the time sirius
enrolled at hogwarts the black family
had fallen from one of the most
dominating in britain to one of the
weakest sirius represented one of only
two remaining male heirs and thanks to
his kind spirit he wasn't even liked by
the rest of his family
in fact the rest of the pure blood
wizarding world especially those who
were in slytherin looked at sirius as if
he was a great disappointment
and for many years that suspicion was
confirmed when black carried out a life
sentence in azkaban harry potter's
father james was the third member of the
group almost the exact opposite of his
son james was born into a rich family
and was spoiled every day of his life
drawing similarities to draco malfoy
james wandered the halls of hogwarts
confident in his social standing
whenever james opened his mouth and cast
a cutting comment in another student's
direction they were expected to simply
absorb it without standing up for
themselves if they didn't and actually
tried to go tit-for-tat with james then
they'd become the object of the
marauders bullying for years to come
the final member of the group was a
mousy boy named peter pettigrew a bit of
a tagalong friend
peter didn't seem to add much to the
marauders he wasn't very courageous nor
very smart if the other three boys were
any crueler they would have treated
peter as a pest rather than a proper
friend and perhaps that would have been
wiser since in the end peter was
responsible for the death of one of
their most courageous members james
potter
as you can see the boys at the time were
hardly the type to create one of the
most influential magical artifacts of
the second wizarding war
but they did
the question is how
the spell well it all starts with a
spell but not something simple like
ascendio or the bubble head charm when
the four members of the marauders put
their heads together and work towards a
common goal of tracking the inhabitants
of hogwarts they decided that only one
spell could do the trick the homunculus
charm
this advanced spell wasn't very easy to
learn
had this been another one of their
potions professors boring assignments
the boys might have only put in a
passing effort but the marauders were
eager to explore the castle and excited
to uncover mysteries
after perfecting the charm they cast it
on a sprawling piece of brown parchment
in the seconds that followed they
marveled as the footsteps of their
classmates and teachers filled the paper
the boys had already charted a rough
drawing of hogwarts corridors and rooms
on the parchment but armed with the
exact whereabouts of the school's
faculty and their tattle-telling peers
the boys could continue to explore all
of its secrets as an extra insult the
former orders added an extra charm to
their map by that point in their studies
at hogwarts the four of them had already
found enough common enemies to fill a
book
as gryffindor's they let their house
pride guide them into an age-old rivalry
against slytherin students
that in turn led them to naturally
despise severus snape who wasn't one to
turn a blind eye to the hurtful comments
that others tossed his way adding fuel
to this fire the marauders enchanted
their map so that if snape ever tried to
use it the ink would form extremely
distasteful barbs about snape's
appearance or intellect
in all other cases the map was available
for anyone to use provided they knew how
to unlock it all a wizard or wedge had
to do was hold the tip of their wand
onto the map
then say i solemnly swear that i'm up to
no good
with that simple incantation the map
would come to life and fill its pages
with every nook and cranny within the
castle
the map even had a special feature if
you ever encountered a
password-protected threshold or door the
map would reveal the password within its
pages
limitations
now this might surprise you but the
marauders map wasn't perfect
although it's often flaunted as the
end-all-be-all device for trekking your
way around hogwarts it didn't show its
users everything
the map only showed what the original
marauders were able to discover but even
this was limited there were places
within hogwarts that were enchanted so
that they couldn't be placed on a map
salazar slytherin's infamous chamber of
secrets which was one of his many
unknown creations never appeared on the
map and the room of requirement the
place where harry potter trained
dumbledore's army in the mid-1990s was
another place that would never appear on
the map but that wasn't all these
unmapped rooms added an additional
wrinkle into the marauder's original
plan of tracking the whereabouts of
everyone at hogwarts whenever someone
was within them they would disappear off
of the map
that must have added an extra layer of
chaos whenever james sirius peter and
remus wandered around the halls at night
worried about who they might encounter
when it came to the escalation of
conflict in the years preceding the
second wizarding war the limitations of
the marauders map revealed themselves
more and more
at one point barty crouch jr consumed
polyjuice potion to disguise himself as
hogwarts new defense against a dark arts
professor
acting on behalf of lord voldemort
crouch jr worked tirelessly to ensure
that harry would be available for the
dark lord's resurrection scheme
although harry potter wasn't overly
obsessed with tracking the whereabouts
of barty crouch jr if the name ever
appeared on the map he surely would have
noticed but that's why one of the map's
weaknesses ultimately revealed itself
even though barty crouch jr had consumed
polyjuice potion the map would reveal
his true name
just like it did when peter pettigrew
was hidden in his animagus form scabbers
and it did but not just the full name
instead it simply inked bharti crouch on
its pages and harry wrongly assumed that
the dark wizard's father the
well-meaning employee of the ministry of
magic was within hogwarts for some
reason
had the marauders charm the map to
reveal a person's full name then perhaps
harry would have never fallen for the
tri-wizard scheme
maps fate the original marauders only
had a short time with the map before
hogwarts groundskeeper argus filch
snatched it away
the boys and filch had been at odds
throughout their time at hogwarts and
filch was beaming with pride when he
finally put an end to their mischief and
got his hands on the parchment
through the years the map remained in
filter's office for a brief time in the
late 80s the map was stolen and used by
montangus fletcher but eventually it
found its way back to filch until fred
and george weasley got their hands on it
together the boys used it to sneak back
and forth between hogwarts and hogsmeade
after harry enrolled in hogwarts the
twins passed the parchment to him
it stayed with potter through the years
it followed until his own son james
potter ii stole it and that's it for
this video if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
you